If we dumped a puddle of liquid nitrogen
Straight into the palm of our hand
How long do you think it would take for the skin to cool down enough to where the nitrogen can latch on and bite it?
Now in previous videos, I showed you that you can take liquid nitrogen and splash it in your face
Or roll it off your hands with little to no effect
And that's because the Leidenfrost effect basically vaporizes the nitrogen into a gas which shields you from the intense cold of this liquid
But what do you think would happen if we left the nitrogen in one place for a little bit too long? For example...
What if we pour this into our hands and just let it sit?
Now for it to take a little bit this liquid and just pour it in the palm of our hand
But we keep our hand moving fast enough. You can see the liquid doesn't actually do any damage
Just skittles around kinda like playing a game of air hockey until the nitrogen completely evaporates
But what would happen if we stop moving our hand and let the liquid nitrogen settle down and stay in one place for a little bit longer?
Okay, so this is where I start getting a little bit more nervous
I don't want to stop moving my hand because I know what's gonna happen
But watch this if I do stop for a second watch right there you can see it actually instantly frostbites the skin
Let's do that again with a little bit more liquid, that's quite a bit Just gonna-
Whoa, you can see immediately it starts frostbiting me and as it warms up it disappears as quickly as it can
Now to me this feels like a little bit of a bee sting
Almost like he got stung and the pain lingers for about 10 to 20 seconds
You can see the skin is turning a little bit red there
It's not to the point will be a first-degree burn just yet, but it would be if we left it exposed a little bit longer
Let's try a smaller bead here let that settle down. Oh my, ooh, ok I chickened out
I don't really want to keep this going much longer
I'm gonna try one little bead and see if I can make it all the way through
This may not be the smartest idea, but I'm doing this for you
There we go, there's a nice little bead will let it settle down and oh
Oh man that kinda actually hurt
You can see it's turned my skin completely white as it warms back up though it starts to fade and see this is taking about
10 to 15 seconds now I do feel a little bit of pain there it is a lingering sensation that
Feels like after you got stung by a bee you see the coloration in hand is a little bit more red
but even at this point
I wouldn't consider that a first-degree burn you might be an extreme case of frostnip
But I wouldn't expect that to blister up you can see it only takes a fraction of a second for nitrogen to actually grab on
your skin and start burning it and the reason I say burn is because
Frostbite is actually very similar to first second and third-degree burns depending on how long you're exposed
I want to show you this reaction because I've done a lot of experiments with liquid nitrogen
And I didn't want you to get the impression that it was super safe stuff to play with you can see that it will burn you
And it'll burn you very quickly and it does hurt and leaves a mark. You might be wondering what this feels like and right now
I have lingering
Sensations all over my hands if I was stung by bees multiple times there is a lingering pain in that part of my hand almost
Like somebody's taking a nail and pressing it down into my skin
I get an itchy tingling sensation that makes you want to scratch it. So if you do happen to get frostbitten
This is the way that you want to treat it
Get yourself a bowl of Lukewarm water you do not want it to be hot and you don't want to be called just lukewarm room temperature
And just soak the area for a couple of minutes until it starts to feel better then take a warm dry cloth and press it
To the affected area and just hold it until it starts to warm back up
Now depending on the severity you might want to go seek medical attention and see what your doctor has to say
So how long does it take for liquid nitrogen to freeze your skin?
According to my experiments it only takes a fraction of a second if you leave your skin exposing longer than that
It's going to start freezing the muscles freezing the tendons you could actually get to the point where you freeze your entire hand solid that would
Not be a very good day. That's all I got for this experiment. I'll see in the next video. Talk to you then
*punching sound effect*
*leaf crunching*
*punch*